hey I'm Dillon Francis and I'm here to
answer questions about DJing deci Ferb a
dude's a producer and a DJ what do djs
do mix songs live find me one electronic
artist who uses only solely their music
in their sets deadmau5 uses solely his
own music and sets you know a lot of
people get angry when they like to but a
DJ is just playing some other person
songs but the thing is you've seen bad
djs and you've seen good DJs and there's
people that know how to read a crowd and
there's people that don't know how to
read a crowd but there's a whole
knowledge behind that rather than it
just being some guy coming in mixing
songs I'm gonna assume my dad would be
the worst DJ ever because if he went to
DJ probably only play like Sammy Hagar's
music a for OGG 17 I had a dream I was
deejaying with Pauly D and Dillon
Francis what kind of combination is that
they were actually pretty good it's a
combination of a little Los Angeles boy
and a little boy from Jersey and it's
just a nice East Coast West Coast
sandwich Maryland Kel's asks how did
DJ's feel when no one is dancing to
their music it hurts if anything it's
kind of like that commercial where the
Sarah McLachlan song starts playing I
feel like one of those better thanks for
that question Marilyn dude from Twitter
how did DJ's do that every weekend
here's B all up you get these
things called ear plugs and your ears
are gonna be fine so if you want to be a
DJ go to the ear doctor get some ear
plugs and you're gonna be good all right
this is from Arvind ji do DJs dance
that's that's an easy question yeah of
course
come on of course we do we're dancing
the whole time Dominic Carter is a
friend of mine actually really curious
what's next in terms of DJ hardware more
specifically in the DJing without a
laptop space in terms of DJ hardware I
think that see DJ's they're gonna
definitely have to get as good as vinyl
in terms of being able to cut I know a
lot of people that cut on see DJ's
there's a lot of lag time with the new
pioneer mixers that they have coming up
there's more effects more blooping that
you can do it's almost as if you had
Ableton on your mixer but anyways I
don't care
loveyou Domenic Christopher Rhys says
how do DJ's deal with the shits in the
middle of a five-hour set that's so
funny because I've recently
thinking about this I've definitely ran
to the bathroom really quickly while I'm
playing in Vegas just if I have to go I
have to go I do know that Diplo
definitely had diarrhea during one of
his sets I think what you should do now
is get him on the show so that he can
explain that because it I think there's
a story I remember we were talking
recently about this Diplo
how do you deal with diarrhea during
sets let me know whirling the mop says
has bass drops circulated out of the
English language yet no no definitely
not it's thriving Biebs Jordan asks if I
do record box I'm still debating
flagship controller or CDJs and djm also
pioneer technics Stanton or Denon for
turntables if you're planning on going
out to DJ they're gonna have a pioneer
set up because that's just the standard
this is what I use and I've heard the
Denon stuff is really cool all the other
ones you listed that's vinyl stuff the
only person I know that uses vinyl now
still is DJ snake underscore no
underscore vah how do deejays mix
without headphones asking for a friend
one of my friends tjr he can mix on CDJs
without headphones and on cerrado
there's lines that you can line up and
if you know how music is created you can
kind of tell where you are in a song
most stuff it's not gonna be that
sporadic and crazy Samir
10:17 you ever see somebody you know
just join the EDM scene and instantly
become more okay sorry I love what this
guy's saying already this dude
you ever see somebody and you just
you're like you just joined the EDM
scene and instantly become more heady
slash book than anybody you've seen at
any show or festival I don't know what
that means
I don't cuz we're not smoking as much
weed as you Samir 10:17 so it's a weird
question and I don't know how to answer
it and this is from MA
China is being better at beat-matching
in one ear over the other thing know
what I think that's just because most
people have their headphones here and
it's just easier to do this rather than
doing this also there's booth monitors
so you can hear the other song I know a
lot of people put on this cue
and that's the master Q so let's
everything that you'll be hearing that's
coming out and then they'll also put on
this this is mostly for people that do
record box even when I'm DJing with
record box though I DJ from one cue and
it's from mixing like that and then I'll
have the booth monitor up so I can hear
the other song playing and I'll keep
cueing from this you know and then
that's all I mix in I don't like to hear
anything else and that's why it's good
to have one headphone like that so
Mixmag does the DJ have to be perfect is
it about selection or perfect beat
matching there'll be certain times where
you can have an amazing set that doesn't
have beat matching it's more of a vibe
that you're going with it's as if you
were watching a movie you wouldn't want
to see the movie all the sudden have
either a black or a white frame because
it would disconnect you from what just
happened if you do a really bad mix
someone's gonna be like what hold on I'm
gonna go get a drink so let's see if I
have perfect beat matching and selection
so I put a little folder right here and
I'm gonna use one headphone to mix so as
you can see as I'm moving the right CDJ
you can see these lines passing each
other and right now there's these other
white lines on the screen where it says
49 that's the one of the song so that's
where you want to match up those lines
and then if you press it at the same
time
right here
[Music]
there you go it's a perfect mix that's
it
that's deejaying in a nutshell it's way
harder than that I think so the song
that I was playing get low and hello
there I sped get low up from 101 to 107
BPM and I slowed down hello there from
114 to 107 ppm and that's how you can
beat match up this is TM SV music DJ's
how do you start your music i folder
structure with BPM genres record box
dorado tractor tags with all the files
in one I like this question because my
library sucks in cerrado
- utley label all songs that I like with
a pink tag now I definitely have some
folders here that say new house new
twerk new trap and that's not that's
like as a new music that I got that's in
that genre that is not a complete
library I tried I just stopped doing it
it definitely helps to have the crowd be
into it cuz that helps you pick
selections it's really just trying to
pick the first song picking the first
song always depends on the DJ before you
I'm usually relying on both my memory
and my folders mmz mark Hikari
what do djs do for pranks on tour cut
the Wi-Fi guys the other DJ during his
set just a thought man Skype a DJ during
their set what a prank dude last night
did you
he Skyped him it was crazy he pranked
him so hard he didn't even know who was
on the phone I've definitely gotten
pranked
I got pranked by DJ snake I was up on
stage with him we were playing our song
get low song starts playing I see him
laughing at me I'm like I don't know
what I did is is my penis hanging out
but no it was even worse he put my phone
number on the jumbotron my phone
was dead at within 30 minutes because it
got so many text messages I have I have
a prank for DJ snake I haven't used it
yet and it's just been waiting in my
back pocket Alex the fab 33 asks do DJ's
go to other DJ's shows just to throw the
down
or no late-night thoughts yes DJ's do go
to other shows to either listen to what
they're playing or to do a back-to-back
set there's less pressure on you once
another DJ is there and especially if
it's too
bigger DJ's then you can kind of do
whatever because they're just happy yes
d HUS 91 asks how do you use cerrado
with CDJs super easy you connect the
cerrado to the pioneer this little RCA
cable instead of going straight into the
mixer you put it into the inputs of the
rain box and then the outputs you go
into what would be your right and then
your left and then you have control CDs
which control all this stuff so now I
can go like that and I can go like this
and it's super easy and everything's in
the computer it's exactly like using
CDJs without sarado just all your music
library is on the CDJs now but through a
computer and they have a control CD that
controls the songs on them so it's as if
you've had these songs queued up on your
SD card or something but you're using
your computer instead at underscore l
underscore what's the cheapest
alternative to buying a stand for CD
days so they sit over turntables
everything is this oh you know what I
got a good idea
throw out your turntables and don't use
them anymore and just use CDJs cuz no
one uses turntables anymore except for
DJ snake is fod dillon francis are you
alive as DJ console abducted you are you
being forced to go one deeper against
your will
where's Dylan one deeper I'm good I
don't even know where that came from
thanks for worrying about me though I'm
fine thank you DJ sicko fantasy serious
note I feel like C DJ's play way louder
than controllers naturally anyone else
find this I find t DJ volume really
distressing i've always wondered that as
well i always thought that CDJs if
you're going straight from CDJs into
mixer i've heard that it sounds better
than going from Serato or anything else
because that's one less thing that it
has to go through this is you know zero
one zero zero one's just being sent into
this you know if you can cut technology
from going from one thing to another
that i it's definitely gonna sound
better
frogs zeros seven-30 dillon francis the
DJ hanzo not make the top 100 DJs
because the list didn't even up yeah yep
voodoo NOLA what's your favorite Dillon
Francis say last remix I would have to
say the one that I did
Francis and moxie remix and then the
epic one death took one's really good
this is the last question Jake uh fur
man says do DJ's get a sore neck from
bobbing their head like after a long set
so they have to get back to the room and
ice their neck no no that actually
doesn't happen but my back was really
messed up and I had to actually I went
and got an MRI because I thought I had a
back problem and I don't but I think it
was because I was playing hunched over
so much recently I've been trying to
push my body out more trying to play
like this now if you don't want a bad
back don't become a DJ